[Music]
I met this man who is mr. K on NBC's go
on he has gone on to other shows
including mr. Mercedes right here on
audience that returns for season three
and September also stranger things can't
get any hotter show than that on Netflix
as well as fleabag on Amazon
good to see you Brett Gelman great to
see you rich yeah you Brockman um to use
the phrase some time when we had Rob
Lowe on our show recently and he said
that who was it that that always
shortened the name of Tom Cruise okay so
we did a couple episodes of go together
oh yeah or on wood which one I think
it's go we did some on together I did
that yeah yeah and it's funny like good
you know we we did some goon together
did and that was always fun that was a
fun being on that set it was a fun set
yeah it was really everybody got along
really well and it was I really loved
playing that character I got like a
chance to play like my archetypical the
archetypical like sitcom NBC sitcom
weirdo right
yeah like the Kramer exactly go on or
the Reverend Jim yes Matthew Perry would
say I like the Reverend Jim of the show
yeah no kidding just cool I love you
know Christopher Lloyd sure than that
show and everything is well you're great
you're great and everything that you're
doing oh my god thank you I mean so much
coming
oh no I appreciate you even saying that
and I appreciate you being here where
are you from originally
where are you from I'm from the suburbs
of Chicago okay a suburb called Highland
Park don't refer to that yeah okay so
does that make does that make you Cubs
White Sox what does that make you here
well it was kind of like split there but
I think it was Cubs I think I was Cubs
but I was always I was never like
completely loyal okay you know but uh
yeah so I think it was Cubs but my uncle
and my cousins were like diehard White
Sox fans okay I ever wore Cubs fur
paraphernalia that would get really
upset well that's a problem you need to
avoid all that right now
so I didn't wear it on them about you're
a Bulls guy from any any money's a Bulls
guy yeah
no I was really lucky to grow up getting
to go to those games in Milan in the old
Chicago State yes yeah the old brick
building that he's actually fit inside
the entire United Center right yeah yeah
I went I went to a lot of a lot of games
there okay yeah there's a beginning of
the the Jordan era pretty I was like
before before there were you know
Championships being won I was you know I
was seen and then and Jordan lived in my
hometown to see so was Jordan a neighbor
of yours around and his cars you know
one time though on the on the school bus
yes uh he was in back of our school bus
and his vet said air one and then he saw
like the visor and we're all like we're
all like at the back of the bus
screaming no movement no acknowledgement
from so ornament you're on your school
bus yeah looking out the back of your
school yeah and you see Jordans driving
behind your school bus yes it was crazy
and he made no acknowledgement of the
you know not even a courtesy way no no
no I don't think that's Jordans either
no one time Pippen was too I was like I
was Pippen tailgating me on the highway
one time it was like this red BMW
convertible behind me I was like what's
going on with this guy what's his
problem
yeah and I'm like you know giving him
the finger out the window and then he
just like zoom by me like I did I did my
anger left though very quickly
as I saw that it was him oh you could do
whatever you want yeah you know what
road rage quickly slips away when a top
50 all-time NBA player that's one unit a
multiple championship exactly exactly so
we were on the way to the game one time
and like we were running late and then
we see black that air1 booking it down
the highway and we're like Oh Michaels
late but the craziest Michael Jordan
thing that happened to me is that a
trick-or-treated at his house okay now
now we're getting somewhere here yeah
okay so walk me through this Brett
Gelman here so it was like the last it
was like the first Halloween where me
and my friends we didn't wear costumes
and so thanks oh you're not wearing
costumes anymore you've become like
hoodlums and vandals so you're like
you've opted out of the costume notes
start wearing like black hoodies and
yeah instead of you know bags for candy
you have shaving cream cans and eggs and
so you're more into the trick part of it
yeah we're definitely we went like away
from treat for the first year and went
very heavily into trick and so us and
like a bunch of kids from the school
there was like a planned like shaving
cream rumble essentially where we like
met on a street to just like just Chuck
a bunch of eggs and cover each other and
shaving cream so we got together we
started doing that the cops of course
came we booked it me and like a few
friends and then suddenly we found
ourselves like in the middle of this
neighborhood and one of the guys I was
with was like hey I think Michael Jordan
lives near here and this is like right
when he had become like the best yes but
wasn't so famous that he couldn't even
even needed to gate himself from so
we're too rich Jews of my community
so we're talking like late 90s here um
pretty much yeah or like yeah or maybe
you know like mid 90s we're talking
maybe late night win it won a
championship
okay Collins is the color I was in
junior high okay Charles Oakley is B is
helping uh maybe Michael try and win yes
yeah I know I think it was it was pre
Jackson it was previously bad boy the
Detroit stage and so uh so we're like
yeah let's go even though we're not in
costume let's go uh trick-or-treat at
his house so we go to his house
we bring his doorbell and he answers the
door which we couldn't believe I mean I
thought was gonna be like a butler or
something and uh yeah he answers the
door and we're just standing there like
shaking like oh my god I can't believe
anyone huh - Chen Trick Trick or Treat
right I mean just like nods to us walks
to the bowl that he's got like oh yeah
table yeah in the foyer again gave us
Big Mac coupons free big yeah
just like him to the tea even in
trick-or-treating I never used it I
never used it never of course you just
write my name framin and I don't know
where it is it's like gonna bend it
somewhere expiration date yeah no I know
but like I would love to have it so I
can be like you know the greatest you
know the greatest gave this to me and
then we were like uh thank you so much
he was like happy Halloween it was crazy
certificate so basically he didn't pay
for what he was giving out no no
definitely not and why would he why
would he I would be disappointed if he
did he's so on brand I know this wasn't
so Mays what a story
crazy Brett Gelman here on the Rich
Eisen show is amazing yeah all right
let's talk about some of your some of
your projects if we can call it that
stranger thing yeah is as huge a
television hit is there is anywhere and
you are sprays II you are speaking
Russian in this show I am do you know
how to actually speak the language or if
you've been hooked on phonics here how
do we are you I wish I did I wish I did
but uh but I also wish I didn't because
it makes me look way more impressive as
an actor that I don't didn't know the
long you're going you're you're method
acting is what you're doing right a
volley out to a degree yeah no I spent
months and rush
no I yeah no I had a coach and like it's
funny I was at a bar the other night in
the this woman this Russian woman came
up and just started speaking to me which
I guess is the highest compliment I get
just aspect of my performance did you
understand which I had no idea
no I only learned the lines rich but you
know I repeated them and and went over
what yeah you know of course like Alec
who plays Alexi was saying to me so that
I understood what he was saying but yeah
there was an understanding of those
scenes but not nothing beyond that
absolutely not
it's so hard make me beautiful years so
it is amazing what this show has become
isn't it though it's crazy it's crazy
it's like a real thrill to be a part of
it and it's also funny because there's
like kind of like a disconnect of when
you're working on it cuz it feels like
this it's this familial environment you
know it's it feels small in a way even
though you're doing like these big set
pieces at times right but like it's
crazy that when you you know you're on
that red carpet and it's like you're on
like a Star Wars or Marvel level there's
carpet and reception yes and and you
know these like you know kids are just
being screamed at like they're like the
Beatles you know and but then you know
third third these great kids you know
all the kids on there great so it's wild
but it's so cool because not only is it
I really think it's an incredible show
is there a season for and and talks
right now um I think so yeah I mean I
don't know if I'm a part of it yet but I
hope I am oh my gosh I mean they better
what the hell I don't know you know I
yeah I I hope so
you know cuz I really I really love the
show and I love working with everybody
on it man rough stuff for true
visionaries you know and as if that's
not enough fleabag is as critically
acclaimed as they come you are fantastic
in that show thank you thank you so much
is that a good thing that you play a
believable dirtbag yeah I mean I think
so I mean I think so I mean I I uh yeah
because they you know them people see me
in life and they're like oh my god
you're the nicest person I've ever met
oh my god I love you so much that's good
sexually awkward guy that no you know
everybody always comes up to me and is
like hey I hate you but I love you and
like okay cool thank you know I I have a
look a lot of empathy for that character
I think that he's I don't think down
deep like deep deep down he's a bad guy
I think he is incredibly messed up and
like hates himself too like the most
that a person can he's an alcoholic so
you're not really with those comment you
know you're not really gonna be acting
right with that recipe you know right
and I was telling you you know off off
in our green room that my why
and I have watched it and it's funny
like we're both laughing at different
parts of the show you come at it from
different angles yeah you know and it's
it really is it's funny and it makes you
think and it's it's great I'm yeah
that's like the mark of a great show I
think that it can like connect on on
several levels you know in different
ways right and then you've got mr.
Mercedes it's returning to audience
coming up in September 10th have you met
Stephen King is he not unfortunately
have not met Stephen King that wouldn't
be amazing I can't believe that I'm you
know in something that was born from his
mind like crazy I know and I hope I get
to meet him so I can tell him how much I
what's your favorite Stephen King if you
had to pick one out my favorite Stephen
King I think you know I think it might
be the shining I'm with you yeah that's
that's really something it's that stuff
I love misery
obviously there yeah it was another
great one of course and then you know
you could we could go in the other
direction Stand By Me is technically
even can love the Running Man
yeah Steve exactly okay I mean and
Shawshank ya know there's so many needs
like this person who just uh he's
omnipresent in our culture Ryan is like
help shape it you know no question about
it and then the running man is the only
Stephen King vehicle that gave us
richard dawson as an evil game show host
which for me is like that's the ultimate
right then and there
yeah and he was amazing he's brilliant
in that I really is bill hit him giving
out the Running Man home game man just
one quick snippet before he sent Jim
Brown and Jesse I think it was the body
body man I'm sure they're all to
untimely demise --is spoiler alert great
stuff I know I know
you know seeing Jesse the body and
anything from bat he's always a predator
we went down a Sean young wormhole and
then he sat down at first and she was in
no way out
exactly and great hackman performance
yes and I always have to
bring up things and put it into sports
perspective for for anybody who's out
there and of course of course Sean Young
played the villain in H Ventura pet
detective
she did she did bring this full circle
because I sort of right now am dressed
like a dark very stylish version of a
spec it's like if you turned it all
black on Ace Ventura and made it a
little more fitted yes and you know gave
them some shoes without saw you do by
the way you alright even you went so you
went side buckle dress you did yeah a
novel side buckle no socks and these
like capri pants do they're like you
know they're like you know they're
cropped you know we're into this like
cropped look no sock look right I love
that we've been going with I know well
you see look at those ankles I mean oh
just parts of your family did not want
you to wear white socks it looks like
you did today oh well my family loves my
ankles almost in an inappropriate way
see now it sounds like fleabag hiking up
too much though they're almost like over
my cap no it's fine by the way in terms
of showing off ankles and calves
absolutely now that so not many people
can can can pull off the trifecta that
you're pulling off right now thank you
mister Mercedes where you play actually
decent attorney-at-law
coming up in September 10th is when the
10 episode season premieres right here
in the audience at 10 p.m. Eastern and
Pacific and then of course fleabag and
stranger things as well and and by the
way incredible Michael Jordan's story
thank you like it oh my god you go you
go trick-or-treating and Michael Jordan
answers his door in the late 80s and
gives out
Big Mac gift certificates crazy right I
wouldn't want it any other way quite
honestly I know you know if you gave me
Kit Kat I'd be like are you sir break it
Kat otherwise get this out of my face I
know it doesn't like if he just gave you
regular candy or bottles of Gatorade ya
know even that's but just I mean that's
Big Mac that's a hell of a payoff right
it is and I'm sure they may be floated
by him like you want Big Macs like
actual Big Macs and he had the
wherewithal to be like no those will get
cold right just call it talk he goes
David yeah I got trick or treat these
kids these these kids who are out of
their their youthful costume part of
their lives or their their kind of their
covering around the golf whatever the
hell they're coming gonna come ringing
at my bell I think it I got to give him
something so I know hand me these Big
Mac gift certificates yeah and then he
was like ooh I got a I got a move to a
gated you were tailgated by every bull
except luc longley it's like at some
point in your life no I know Horace
Grant rear-ended me wanted no he did it
he did it in a parking lot Brett Gelman
on Instagram where you have quite the
following as you're as you say your
mother likes to point out to your right
the chin she likes to update my
following on there but it's not like as
huge as many you know it's taking all
good the summer of Gelman continues good
to see you Brett great to see you back
any time bro my god please you got it
had the best time we'll finish up this
show and set up the rest of the week in
a moment for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app